on est notre invité du jour 1c vous
christian lequesne bonjour vous êtes
professeur à sciences po paris
spécialiste des questions de diplomatie
ça tombe bien on va commencer par
aborder cette réunion du jour organisée
par l'elysée sous le format 10 de
normandie ça pourrait être un outil
efficace pour la crise en ukraine
écoutez c'est mieux que rien parce que
ça permet au moins aux européens ou à
certains européens les deux grands pays
que sont la france et l'allemagne de
parler directement avec les russes et
les ukrainiens et surtout avec les
russes car comme vous le savez toute la
stratégie russe depuis le début de cette
crise a consisté à laisser les européens
de côté en ne considérant les états unis
que comme le seul interlocuteur
or ça c'est quand même une forme
d'humiliation de la part de la part de
la russie qui est qui est inacceptable
est-ce qu'il n'est pas une question
d'ego là aussi on a évoqué dans les
précédentes éditions les égos russes et
américains on sent bien cette escalade
et cette surenchère dans la rhétorique
chacun veut montrer ses muscles les
européens qui tentent de faire entendre
la voix malgré tout au milieu de tout
cela mais le succès reste assez limitée
assurent certains on a entendu les mots
sergueï lavrov ce matin qui balaie de la
main toute tentative diplomatique la
russie ne négociera pas avec l'union
européenne bce
écoutez ce qui est certain c'est que ce
sont des perceptions et des
représentations qui repose sur du côté
russe l'esprit de revanche oui
les russes n'ont finalement pas accepter
le fait que l'otan
ait pu s'élargir à alès ils l'ont dit
très très ouvertement dans le début de
la crise ils ne veulent pas absolument
pas accepter le fait que
le crès qui est tout de même un état
souverain puisse préférer
ils ont la direction de l'occident que
la leur et à partir de là eh bien
il met en avant une stratégie qui
consiste à
impliquer le rapport de forces est à
dire voilà c'est notre jeune influence
l'ukraine et il n'y a pas de négociation
possible donc on est dans une
forme de diplomatie si vous voulez qui
est une diplomatie agressive un peu à
l'ancienne
emmanuel macron aux mines tout ça on l'a
vu dès hier soir à berlin aux côtés de
la fiole se pose comme médiateur il va
s'entretenir par téléphone elle a bien
insisté là dessus avec vladimir poutine
ce vendredi à a priori on va écouter
emmanuel macron s'exprimer à ce sujet on
irait juste après j'aurai un échange
vendredi matin avec le président poutine
ce n'est pas un déplacement ce sera un
échange téléphonique qui aura pour but
de faire un point sur l'ensemble de la
situation et d'essayer de justement
obtenir de la visibilité
engager un dialogue exigeant et obtenir
des clarifications sur plusieurs des
points en cas d'agression et comme cela
a été dit s'il devait y avoir une
agression
la riposte sera là et le coût sera très
élevé
on sent bien la volonté de l'intention
lorsque le chef de l'état prend le temps
de formuler ses mots à l'adresse des
autorités russes est ce qu'ils vont
faire écho seulement au kremlin
écoutez je ne sais pas quelle quelle
riposte
emmanuel macron en tête
par les sanctions ainsi la tuque ont les
européens sont quand même
tout à fait d'accord pour dire qu'on
peut continuer les sanctions mais ça ne
semble pas dissuader les russes pour
autant alors bien sûr il est très bien
que le président français
ouvre un canal diplomatique et les rues
je préfère toujours la voie bilatérale à
la voix de l'europe notamment avec ce
qu'il considère être les grands états
ils perçoivent la france comme tel mais
ça ne suffit pas je veux dire monsieur
me suis macron ne pourra pas faire de
miracle si les russes ont décidé
vraiment d'engager des troupes au moins
2 watts février ce qui est inquiétant
c'est la position ce qui est inquiétant
c'est la position très très ferme de
lavrov ce matin sous le refus de
négociation avec avec l'union européenne
en tant que telle et luis e d'où cette
interrogation effectivement sur l'issue
de ces négociations en 2 + 2 organisé
aujourd'hui à paris qu'est ce que cela
vous inspire tous ces mouvements ces
manoeuvres militaires il est évidemment
question de posture on en parlait juste
avant mon après ce matin que les russes
des navires russes
engagés des manoeuvres en mer de barents
on est loin d'un apaisement l'escaladé
elle continue
ça rappelle quand même la situation que
qui prévalait en europe de 30 ans en
arrière c'était une espèce de guerre que
l'on appelait à l'époque que guerre
guerre froide ça veut dire aussi que
clairement les pays autoritaires et je
pense bien sûr là la russie en
particulier ont décidé aujourd'hui de ne
plus mettre les formes et et ça c'est
très inquiétant pour le système
international parce que si vous prenez
le cas de la chine c'est exactement la
même chose les provocations qui sont
faites régulièrement à taiwan par par la
chine montre que voilà ce pays autres
figures de l'autoritarisme ne met plus
les formes non plus dans le système
international donc ça veut dire que
quelque part il y a de la part des pays
autoritaires que sont la russie la chine
et d'autres une volonté de
défier l'occident et de l'ex-siège ceux
qui incarnent ce qu'on appelait l'ordre
libéral internationale est-ce que la
surenchère américaine de ces derniers
jours on pense à l'ordre formulé retrait
de tous les ressortissants américains
ducret non on pense aussi à cette
annonce du pentagone qui a annoncé avoir
placé en alerte 8500 gi's en cas
d'intervention nécessaires à l'est de
l'europe n'a pas contribué justement à
pousser les russes à accélérer ou assis
dans leurs surenchères
pour ce qui est des troupes américaines
et des manoeuvres aussi la marine
américaine notamment mer noire je pense
que je pense que non
le fait de retirer des
fin de demander aux américains aux
citoyens de quitter l'ukraine à mon avis
on ça n'a pas tellement joué non plus
sur la position de moscou en revanche
par rapport aux ukrainiens je trouve que
c'est symboliquement assez désastreux ça
veut dire que l'on quitte on quitte déjà
le navire et on donne l'impression que
si les choses si les choses tournent mal
on ne reste pas à ça me moi ça me fait
penser un peu quand même toutes
proportions gardées à l'attitude en
afghanistan je trouve ça je trouve ça
très très dommage parce que ça ça fait
vraiment plaisir monsieur à monsieur
coûté in là encore il peut avoir un
message notamment vis à vis de son
opinion publique ils ont regardé les
américains commencent à s'en aller ils
ont la trouille ils ont peur etc voilà
donc
il faut pas oublier qu'avec des gens
comme comme poutine hélas hélas
le seul langage qu'ils comprennent c'est
le rapport de force justement justement
pour en revenir à cette réunion
organisée à l'elysée aujourd'hui vous
qui êtes un spécialiste de la diplomatie
qu'est-ce qui pourrait parler aux russes
qu'est ce qui pour aller les convaincre
de calmer le jeu
écoutez ce qui peut les convaincre c'est
quand même les arguments les arguments
économiques parce que vous savez ils ont
besoin de nous vendre leurs matières
premières et en particulier
leurs leur pétrole est l'heureux et leur
gaz
nous nous donnons l'impression que nous
sommes très dépendants d'eux au point
d'ailleurs que les allemands comme vous
savez on accepter la construction d'un
pipeline
directement en mer baltique le fameux
north stream 2 qui évite l'ukraine mais
si vous prenez la situation à 10 ans
avec l'évolution nous des nouvelles
sources d'énergie en europe et ils ont
notre green deal nous aurons de moins en
moins besoin des matières premières de
l'art et je trouve que ça c'est un
langage qu'on pourrait le retenir en
leur disant écoutez si vous voulez qu'on
continue à vous acheter des matières
premières
quand même vous êtes priés d'être
coopératif et ne vous placez pas dans le
très court terme placez-vous à une
échéance de 10 ans 1 mais je ne suis pas
sûr que ddd mais dictateur ou des dés
figure autoritaire comme monsieur
poutine se projette à l'échelle de 10
ans il se projette souvent à l'échelle
de la de du court terme et de la
prochaine échéance électorale merci
beaucoup christian lahccen d'avoir été à
nos côtés un pour décrypter ces échanges